we have a large home appliance this
customer
actually approached us about expanding
their portfolio to include
smart applications via an application on
your phone or
any of the voice apps like siri or alexa
they found they were going to have to
revamp their architecture to be able to
support this new model
moving forward
[Music]
what they're using ibm cloud for is our
middleware which is essentially the glue
that holds all their software components
together when you employ premium support
you
have an assigned technical account
manager that oversees your account
and what the technical account manager
can do for a premium support customer
is really coordinate all those efforts
and really bring the right people in
but also you have prioritized ticket
handling
um and access to ibm experts which is
something that we put a lot of value in
at ibm is making sure our customers
are comfortable approaching us and
they're satisfied
you know after after we resolve their
issues some of the problems they
encountered was
downtime on their network it's a
two-pronged approach when we fix these
problems because
we want to fix the problem but we also
want to
make sure it doesn't come back the
multi-zone structure was
the best way to get them to a stable and
scalable environment all at the same
time
if they had any part of their
environment go down a device an
appliance
it could carry over to the next zone so
there is there's no
danger of you know actual outage or
impact
and it really eases the concerns that a
large company would have on implementing
any new products
or new new services into their catalog
this customer specifically was able to
triple their workload after they
moved to a multi-zone architecture
anytime we're able to make a permanent
fix
and you know we can see customer
business growing
or you know any positive impacts from
changes we've implemented
that's always a big win for us
[Music]
you